Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number that you
can call. That number is two one nine two David P.
Here's a good question about a term
that many right wingers have been
using lately. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 9: Hey, David, I was just
watching your bit on the fake scandals
that Fox News is trying to conjure up.
And there was a bit in. Your video about
Newt Gingrich basically saying that
the gay flag flying at embassies is going
against traditional values, right? Well,
what is traditional values? Or sometimes
I hear it as traditional family values,
the assiduity term thrown around a lot by
Republicans, usually in the sense that someone
someone else goes against what they believe. Is
this something that the right demands in order
to be an American when you fly a gay flag that
goes against someone else's, I'm assuming their
religion. Does that not make you an American?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Well, so what the question
of what they mean by traditional values or
traditional family values is a good one.
There's a bunch of interpretations, but my
understanding of traditional family values
is basically a 1950s era perspective of you're
starting to get some equality and egalitarianism
between men and women, but there's still a male
dominated aspect to society. You are starting.
There's no slavery in the 1950s, but there's
still all sorts of racial discrimination.
Abortion has not yet been established
as legal through Roe v. Wade. For me,
it's a 1950s era view, either proactive or
sort of by default. When I hear of traditional
values or traditional family values,
if you see it a different way,
not we don't yet have enshrined rights for
LGBT individuals. If you see it differently,
let me know. But that's what I think of when I
hear about traditional family values. We have a
great bonus show for you today. The Supreme Court
is going to hear a case on the right to carry
concealed guns for self-defense. Important
case. We will discuss it. In New Zealand,
50000 people attended a rock concert. Why? Because
they've gotten rid of the virus in New Zealand. We
will talk about that. And the Census Bureau has
announced the US has 331 million people living in
it and Texas will get two congressional seats.
Very important in terms of the possible future
balance of power in the House of Representatives.
All of these stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a member
at Join Pakman dot com. I will see you then.